in dieser woche hat die
bundesnetzagentur den weg frei gemacht
für 5g den superschnellen mobilfunk
standard höchste zeit
im moment hat ja in deutschland nur das
flugzeug der kanzlerin 5g auch nicht so
kommen wir mal zur traurigen digitalen
realität in deutschland denn das sieht
nicht gut aus 5g nur 30 prozent nutzen
im moment lte also 4g weil mobilfunk bei
uns im europäischen vergleich viel viel
zu teuer ist warum auch wegen oligopol
heißt nur drei große anbieter telekom
vodafone und o2 teilen sich den
deutschen markt und so soll es wohl auch
mit 5 g bleiben denn digitalisierung
muss man sich leisten können von der
sache mit den blöden funklöchern mal
ganz zu schweigen wenn ich mal was mit
dem handy telefonieren möchte dann gehe
ich zum friedhof und da klappt das
durch empfangen aber ich kann ja nicht
immer zum trikot kreml
ich kann ja nicht immer zum friedhof ist
völlig richtig völlig richtig da ist man
später eh viel zu oft es gibt fünf
löcher in brandenburg die sind so groß
wie brandenburg
die haben da ganze 18 funkloch
golfplätze da oben und offizieller
werbepartner der mobilfunkanbieter sind
jetzt übrigens die funkloch wismar und
selbst wenn es selbst wenn es mit 5 g
optimal läuft in bayern bleiben zehn bis
20 prozent der fläche deutschlands weiße
flecken und das kann wirklich jeden
treffen jeden ja auch den einfachsten
wirtschaftsminister aus dem volk ich
habe inzwischen meinem büro meinem büro
erklärt dass sich bitte auf fahrten
nicht mehr mit ausländischen
ministerkollegen verbunden werden möchte
weil es mit total peinlich ist wenn ich
dann dreimal viermal neu anrufen muss
weil ich jedes mal wieder raus fliege ja
gut meistens sind das allerdings keine
funklöcher die kollegen drücken ihn werk
quasi seinen abends gehen an dem ich zum
schluss
ok
ich schlage man müsste die großen
anbieter endlich zwingen ihre funkmasten
untereinander zu teilen
gegen geld natürlich sonst habe ich
nämlich auf bestimmten strecken auch in
zukunft nur mit vodafone empfangen und
gucken wir den anderen in die röhre soll
ich mit drei handys kaufen oder was ich
fürchte liebe zuschauer wir deutschen
bleiben ein volk ohne roaming
dabei steht im koalitionsvertrag zitat
wir entwickeln deutschland zum leitmarkt
für 5 gg und jetzt rudern so ganz an
zurück ihr unsere forschungs ministerin
das ist jetzt auf jeden fall notwendig
bei 5 g ist nicht an jeder milchkanne
notwendig das ist auch wahr
eben da ist auch war er natürlich hat
sie doch recht braucht überhaupt jeder
schnelles internet oder fließend wasser
oder oder ministerin wie anja karliczek
ich meinen 1 5 g stellt die weichen für
die nächsten jahrzehnte und da werden
wir gerade sauber abgehängt von wegen
autonomes fahren oder digitalisierter
bauernhof bei uns werden ferkel immer
noch mühsam von hand kastriert so
sieht's aus viele bauern sind stinksauer
weil mir so weit die werke handy nicht
realitätsnah
also geht gar nichts mache ich nicht
verstehe eh keiner
[Applaus]
so wird das nichts mit 5 geben man muss
ja mal gucken was die nachbarn machen
sogar die franzosen machen es besser als
wir
da werden die anbieter nämlich zur
flächendeckenden versorgung verpflichtet
vom staat
sonst drohen geldstrafen von bis zu drei
prozent des jahresumsatzes das tut
richtig weh
und was haben wir in der app zum
funklöcher melden ein zusätzlicher
anreiz billiganbieter den wichtigen
ausbau zu forcieren ist wenn die
bürgerinnen und bürger
hallo schreien warte mal hallo wer immer
noch heiss empfangen weil scheuer nicht
die eier hat sich mit der industrie
anzulegen sollen wir hallo rufen vielen
dank auch den start können wir vergessen
in dieser angelegenheit ich sage wir als
gesellschaft wir müssen gemeinsam was
tun
für menschen die hier im wahrsten sinne
des wortes mitten unter uns durchs netz
gefallen sind herzlich willkommen zur
großen zdf-spendengala 1 gigahertz für
kinder
liebe zuschauer schauen wir nicht länger
weg mitten unter uns leben immer noch
deutsche in funklöchern aber kann man
das überhaupt leben nennen dieses vor
sich hin vegetieren mit nur einem oder
gar keine balken und ab wann ist es
ethisch vertretbar diesen menschen die
geräte abzustellen
öffnen sie also ihre herzen und ihre
brieftaschen und spenden sie für neue
funkmasten kleine mittelständische
familienbetriebe wie vodafone oder
telekom können diese jahrhundert
ausgaben nicht alleine stemmen
rufen sie jetzt an auf dem zdf
festnetztelefon und bitte sprechen sie
laut und deutlich denn die leitung ist
von 1960 und unsere mitarbeiter von 1930
denken an die menschen in brandenburg in
rheinland-pfalz oder sogar in teilen
bayerns wenn sie erfolgen dürfen sich
keinen zentimeter bewegen und schied aus
das ist aus parteien das geht mir doch
sehr nah die beiden sitzen da seit über
zehn jahren und bewegen sich nicht
warum leben diese bayern in einem
funkloch aber dorothee bär hat ständig
empfangen und foltert uns täglich mit
ihren bescheuerten instagram fotos hier
wirft sie mit laub hier sitzt sie das
heu platt und hier frisst sie einen
lebenden dackel warum
und warum hilft niemand der gemeinde bad
säckingen in baden württemberg dem
tiefsten funkloch deutschlands wir
schalten da mal live hin zu dieser
milchkanne ohne internet und die politik
tut nichts
der empfang in bad säckingen ist so
miserabel die menschen dort können
ausschließlich lineares fernsehen gucken
also sendungen wie dieser ich will mir
das gar nicht vorstellen
ich würde mich umbringt bitte spenden
sie reichlich und freuen sie sich mit
mir auf unseren heutigen show act das
thema ist für ihn sehr emotional denn er
wurde selber in einem südbadischen
funkloch von schafen großgezogen
max mutzke
[Musik]
bei uns auf dem land ist internet völlig
trocken kein netflix keine worden
da macht sich der bonus ist bei unseren
festen germany ist der empfang komplett
wird das handy aus dem fenster ist von
block 2
[Musik]
auch
b
[Musik]
also stellt euch
und sonst
denn
sein
[Applaus]
jetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es geht
[Musik]
es war noch zeit
[Applaus]
[Musik]